ciao
so he's mario he's our son he was born
two and a half years ago
and i had a pretty tough pregnancy
because i had to stay still in a bed for
like eight months but at the end
everything seemed to be under control so
he got the right weight at birth he got
right upgrade index so we were pretty
reassured by this
but
at the end ten days later when he was
born we discovered that he had a stroke
as you might know a stroke is a brain
injury a perinatal stroke could be
something that can happen during the
nine months of birth of pregnancies or
just suddenly after the birth
and in his case as you can see the right
part of his brain has gone
so the fact that this stroke could have
on mario's body could be the fact that
he couldn't be able to control the left
side of his body
uh just imagine like if you have a
computer and the printer and he won't
transmit the input to print out a
document but the printer doesn't have
the right drivers so
the same is for mary's just like i would
like to move his left side of his body
but he's not able to transmit the right
input to move his
left arm and left leg
so life had to change we need to change
our schedule we need to change
the impact
that
this birth had on our life
as you may imagine
unfortunately we were not ready nobody
teached us how to deal with such kind of
disabilities and as many questions as
possible started to come to our minds
and that has been really a tough time
question some basics like you know
why this happened to us
what went wrong
some more
tough like really what will be the
impact on mario's life i mean at the end
we'll be able to work we'll be able to
be normal and you know as a parent
especially for the first time
y is not going to be better than us
and is indeed really
tough to say but few months later we
realized that
we were really feeling like a failure i
mean that the only real product of our
life at the end was a failure
and you know was not a failure for
ourself in
in itself but it was a failure that will
impact his full life
honestly we went down i mean we went
really down but at the end
we started to look at them and we said
we have to react so immediately as
francesca said we changed our life we
started the physiotherapy we started the
rehabilitation and one of the path that
we were following in terms of
rehabilitation is the mirror neurons
pilot basically we spent months doing
this with mario you have an object
and we showed him how to grab the object
now the theory of mirror neurons simply
say that in your brains exactly now as
you watch me doing this you are
activating exactly the same neurons as
if you do
the actions
it looks like this is the leading edge
in terms of rehabilitation but one day
we found that mario was not
looking at our hand
he was looking at us
we were his mirror and the problem as
you might felt is that we were in down
we were depressed we were looking and
him as a problem
not as a son not from a positive
perspective
and that they really changed our
perspective we realized that we
had to become a better mirror for mario
we started from our strengths and at the
same time we started from his strengths
we stopped to look at him as a problem
and we start to look at him as an
opportunity to improve
and really this was the change and from
our side
we said
what how are our strengths that we
really can bring to mario and we started
from our patients i mean at the end my
wife and myself are quite different but
we have many things in common we love to
travel we love music we love to be in
places like this and we started to bring
mario with us
just to show to him the best things that
we can show to him
this short video is from last week
i'm not saying
i'm not saying it's a miracle that's not
the message because we are just at the
beginning of the part but we want to
share what was the key learning the
learning the mario drove to us and is to
consider what you have as a gift
and not
only what you miss
and to consider what you missed just as
an opportunity and this is the message
that we want to share with you this is
why we
are here
mario
and this is why
[Applause]
we decided to share the best mirror in
the world with him and we thank you so
much all of you thank you thank
you you
[Music]